hi my name is Lutz thanks for having me
I hope you can see my slides now
yeah we can see the slides all right
cool okay so um yeah I'm going to talk
about how to format strings for logging
um
uh just because
um I think so there are different ways
to do it or people like to do it in
different ways and I kind of wanted to
spend a little bit of time on that I'm
just checking or like wanting to see if
there's any
um if there's any better way or so or
what what to what is the the
Alternatives or the benefits of each so
I just wanted to present it very quickly
so um just to recap if you want to
format a string in Python so um there
are different ways to do that and so by
formatting I basically mean adding a
variable into a string so there's this
kind of old style percent s formatting
where you have a placeholder here and
then this percentage sign
and then the variable
um and then let's get kind of like
replaced uh where so the placeholder
gets replaced by the if the variable and
then you also have this Stringer
template class from the standard Library
which looks similar except there's a
dollar sign here for the placeholder
then in Python 3 you have these curly
braces in the string then you can call
these this format method on the string
directly with the variable and then the
last one in Python 36 is are these F
strings which are denoted by an F here
in the front and they look similar to
these um
curly braces to this kind of thing here
but you put the variable directly into
the string without calling a method and
all of these basically produce the same
results
um and now if we look at the logging
module in particular um this has uh even
again a slightly different syntax so you
also so you import the module here and
then if you want to log a message you
also have this percent as a placeholder
here but then you have the variable the
task name which is applied to the
function so this is a little bit
different than the first example here
where you have the string then the
percentage operator and then the
variable and here you um uh here you
pass the variable as a parameter to this
logger.info function
and now you could do this you could
achieve the same thing by um with
navstring where you basically put a
variable directly into
the string and now basically the
question is um is there any um I mean
people like to use fstring for most uh
things
um is my impression but when it comes to
logging a lot of people in a lot of code
bases um still use this kind of like um
which I would call Old notation
um so this upper one here and then the
question is is there anything to this so
is there any reason not to use f strings
in this example and so the reason that
people usually give for using this first
notation is that
um so what logging does when you when
you use this notation it is kind of like
only form it's a string if it's really
necessary so maybe so you can see that
in this example I set the level to
logging.warning so if we call logout and
input so this message will actually not
be printed and so logging um the logging
module realizes this and kind of avoids
formatting a string because it doesn't
need to be formatted because it will not
be printed and on the other hand if you
use fstrings here you can maybe see that
this string gets evaluated immediately
even before it is passed to the info
method and so the argument is if you use
this first notation then you save
yourself some computation basically
because you avoid formatting the string
so let's look at this in a little bit
more detail
so there's this tweet by Raymond
hattinger who's a python developer
basically comparing different methods to
format a string and then so the result
is that F strings are the fastest uh
basically so and then so there's this
percent s uh so this percent notation a
little bit more down so sorry and this
is what the logging module uses
internally if it has the format a string
but since F strings are the fastest
there's a kind of a problem here because
that means let's imagine the level set
to logging info instead of warning and
these messages would be printed then
that means the the bottom one the F
string would actually be faster
um yeah so and so if the message is
printed this one this method is
generally faster if the message is not
printed the upper one is generally
faster so there's no clear
um recommendation or like winner in
terms of speed it kind of depends on the
logging level
so I did some very basic experiments
timing experiments with this
so in this example the level is actually
set to login.info and so here I'm doing
two calls to logging info one with this
like logging notation here and one with
f strings and then the result is
basically that so here the messages are
printed right so the result is that
fstrings a little bit faster so around
890 microseconds um versus the upper one
the logination with 990 microseconds but
the difference is kind of small
especially if you look also look at the
standard deviation
um then I did the same thing here only
this time I'm calling logout.debug so
these messages will not be printed
and you can see here that in this case
this lazy evaluation kind of way of this
first method kind of pays off because
here we have around 280 nanoseconds and
then
with f strings we have because the
strings actually formatted and even
though it's not printed we are around
500 nanoseconds um
so yeah so in this bundle case um the
dissentation is faster in this upper
case where you print a message the F
string is faster
um yeah so what can we make of this um
yeah as I said no clear winner
um
yeah and so what you can also see is
that the absolute number here is a lot
lower so we're here in the nanosecond
range instead of the microsecond range
so not printing a string saves a huge
amount of time in no matter if you
format it or not but so my main point
here from this from these examples is
that the difference are really really
small so even in this um top case where
you um where you print a string you get
at most around maybe nine sorry about
maybe 100 microseconds uh benefit from
using fstrings and um so I would say
that yeah so this is an odd of magnitude
which is not really relevant for most uh
for almost all use cases so it just it
doesn't matter if your program is runs
100 microseconds faster or not so if you
disagree with this if you have a use
case where this kind of speed difference
actually matters then I would love to
hear about it maybe you can write it in
the chat or so but for now my conclusion
is that um it's it's too small to be
practically relevant uh this difference
okay so then I want to very quickly talk
about
um security
um considerations so there's um
um there's this um so let's say you have
a string you want to format with a
method um there are these like um
format specifiers and in this case you
actually you add some white spring white
space here to the string uh to pad it to
nine characters and then the problem is
that's um
you can
um you can make this number arbitrarily
large and so in this case you would
actually print more than one gigabyte of
white space and what happens is that the
program freezes for quite a long time
and then might it might crash depending
on how much how much memory you have
available
um so this is with the string format
method you can do the same thing with
this logging notation
um where you basically give them
variable name and then add these padding
numbers here to the right
um yeah so the point here is that if you
have a situation where this format
string comes from an untrusted source so
basically let's say you have an
application and maybe you want to let
the user control
um the formatting so maybe they can
supply it in the configuration file then
this could be exploited by specifying a
string like this
um so here when you when the see you
have to think about security
and now you can you could maybe ask us
what about fstrings aren't they the same
thing here so in general yes but the
thing with f strings is that they are
evaluate evaluated immediately so you
cannot have the situation that a user
supplies an unformatted f-string that
you format later on so that's why I
would argue that F strings are kind of
safe against this kind of attack because
they don't have this capability of being
formatted later basically
so now if you're wondering um so yeah
which one should you use f strings or
this uh like percent s notation
um so in terms of speed I would say it
doesn't matter
um or almost always so I'm not 100 sure
actually that's why I put this in
Brackets here
um readability counts this is from
design of python and in my opinion that
would speak for f strings I would I
think they are the most readable of all
these string formatting methods that you
have available
and um yeah as I said so if you if the
performance string comes from kind of
like from some kind of external Source
you have to think about security issues
with this
um yeah that was it
um so you can contact me over your email
um if you like um there's also a written
version and also kind of in slightly
extended version of this talk at my um
GitHub profile because I had to cut out
some things I wanted to talk about
because of time so um also feel free to
leave comments there also put some like
references to other links blog posts
that kind of cover this topic and that
I've learned uh learned a lot about when
I put this talk together
so yeah thanks for listening